Speaker 1: Fox News and their medical team is
demanding that before minors are allowed to
avail themselves of any gender affirming
care, there should be steps that have to
be taken. Therapy, for example, blood
tests, physical exams. And of course,
all these things are already happening. I'm
going to show you these clips. This is this is
pretty wild stuff. So Fox News had this panel
with Dr. Marc SIEGEL and some other people,
and they were talking about trans kids. And this
is a very hot button issue right now. It really
agitates the right. It's one of the top issues
they like talking about. Here is one doctor
saying what should be required. Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Your take. Yeah, I completely agree
with Dr. SIEGEL. I mean, she is not the god
of science. Science, you know, medicine,
they call it a practice because it's.
Speaker 1: This is Dr. Janette Nesher.
What? Fox News contributor constantly evolving.
Speaker 2: We need to change our guidelines and
protocols as we progress, as we learn more
information. But gender dysphoria, this is a
very serious and sensitive issue, a very serious
topic, because it has a very high suicide rate,
very high suicidal ideation. Up to 42% of those
who struggle with their identity think about
suicide because of the stress that that it has
on them and even their families. So I don't think
it's right for Rachel Levine to impose esteemed
her personal views on all of us. Instead, we know
that some people will benefit from transitioning
to gender affirming care, but we want to do it
the right way. And that starts off with taking a
history and a physical, maybe doing blood work,
getting counseling and therapy, not rushing to
hormones and irreversible surgeries that might
have long term consequences are irreversible.
Speaker 1: So she has some ideas of things
that should happen before surgeries
take place. Let's watch one more
clip and then we'll talk about this.
Speaker 2: It's about approximately
two thirds. You know, it's just it's.
Dr. SIEGEL, you mentioned that when
should these things be approached.
Speaker 4: With the people, with the.
Speaker 2: Individuals who are
experiencing gender dysphoria?
There's got to be an age that is too young, right?
Speaker 3: Well, for sure, puberty is too young to
be talking about transition. And that's
where all the debating is going on. And
the mental health issues are really important
because 70% or more of those that have gender
dysphoria have major mental health issues
going on simultaneously. We can't sleep that
under the rug. We have to. What's the downside
of counseling right down to seeing a therapist
and working through what you're feeling? Okay.
Speaker 1: So, listen, they have ideas about
what should take place before minors are allowed
to do certain things or even maybe they're talking
about adults here. It's not totally clear, but
they definitely. They seem concerned about miners
that's going on. The requirements vary to some
degree state by state, but generally speaking,
to even get going down this path, there is a
protocol and it does start with the physical
exam and the initial conversation. Oftentimes
there is some blood testing that's done and at
a certain point, a diagnosis is established of
gender dysphoria. Now, some of these folks don't
believe that gender dysphoria is a real thing. But
others say, well, you should actually have to be
diagnosed after going through an initial. Okay,
well, so for those people in that latter group,
you get the diagnosis after an evaluation.
Often it includes a mental health professional,
like a psychologist or a psychiatrist, making
that diagnosis to even be able to enter this
entire path. That's a requirement in just
about every state or requirement part of
the protocol. And they're talking
about protocol. For the most part,
evidence of informed consent is required when
you're talking about minors. Minors may be
required to show that they really understand
the risks, benefits, implications and possible
complications of whatever it is that they're
agreeing with their doctor that they want to
do. And in some cases, this also requires the
informed consent of the parent or guardian,
depends on the state. There's controversial
aspects to that, but that's part of the protocol
already. Again, they're saying they want this
stuff. This is already part of the protocol
three. In order to move to the surgery
component, you often need evidence of long term
hormone therapy as well as therapy talk there,
psychotherapy to talk about and explore how that
is going and whether the surgery is actually the
logical next step. There are states that require
minors to have been taking hormones for a certain
amount of time before they're even eligible for
surgery. And this is to make sure the family, the
individuals, everybody knows. How does this work?
To some degree, it's really the right thing for
me, etc.. And then at the tail end of all of this,
almost always a letter from a mental health
professional who has been involved in this,
often from the get go, saying, Here are
all the things we've done. I believe that
surgery is appropriate and that this individual is
well-suited and predisposed to surgery. Sometimes
that psychotherapy period goes on for a period
of time as well, again, depending on the state.
That's what they say. We listen. We just can't
go around doing this stuff willy nilly. I mean,
what's wrong with therapy and a physical exam and
getting the diagnosis? That's that's the protocol.
That's the protocol. I have still not found and
I am more than willing to review evidence if
anybody has it for me. I have not found any
place you can just kind of show up and say,
I think I'd like surgery. Oh, have you been
diagnosed with gender dysphoria? Have you done
hormone therapy? Have you met with. No, I just
want. Sure, yeah. Next week. Come in and we'll
do the therapy. I've just not heard of that
anywhere in the United States, if it exists.
I want to know more about it. Let me know. But
I was able to find no evidence of it. So I guess
the good news is the protocol that Fox doctors
want to see already is in place. The next step
is getting them to mention that rather than saying
five year olds are getting their breasts cut off,
five year olds have breasts. Well, no, but
they're still doing. Come on, guys. Come on.
We'll have these clips on our Instagram, which
you can find at David Pakman show on Instagram